school officials at Weber middle school
in Long Island not too far from where I
grew up from they are basically banning
fun yeah at recess the kids will no
longer be able to play with items such
as footballs hard soccer balls
baseball's lacrosse balls or anything
that might hurt someone on school
grounds all these things are banned from
reset and this I love rough games of tag
or cartwheels unless supervised by a
coach so if you're being supervised by
the cartwheel coach I guess you could do
a cartwheel this seems just profoundly
awful to me kids need to run around and
do stupid things and fall off
trampolines and monkey bars they need to
exercise their bodies and their brains
please like what is going on such
[ __ ] me to be able to fake injuries
so they can get out of class which is
what I did yeah did you ever go to clegg
you were constantly everything cuz I can
dislocate my shoulder really so I did
that a lot but but it's so it really is
jokes aside it's the most important
thing because would you rather have your
kid outside playing with the chance he
gets hurt say he gets hurt breaks his
arm or her then she gets a really cool
cast and all the kids get to sign it and
she feels cool for a minute or would you
rather have them sitting on the computer
right during recess right so of course
what this is about is they don't want
them out there and there you know
banging up their knees and they're
getting scraped all things that have
happened throughout the course of time
I'm pretty sure then they're taking
recess away it's all for [ __ ] it's all
liability it's it's School District
worried about lawyers worried about
getting sued and it's gonna turn every
one of these [ __ ] kids into a
Republican yeah that's like yeah you
just I get smell it because you know you
like Matt Drudge reads this story right
rather the regulations the Democrats
take it away recess and in this case
this is regulation gone too far like I
mean you're just you're overly involved
here in people's lives let the kids play
football obviously if they're tackling
each other on school property you go up
you go hey you don't you gotta play
touch yeah it's cool yeah it's not
complicated but also they're still gonna
be able to play football they just got
to play it with an
earth football yeah so you can still
hurt someone if you can hurt someone
with in there oh yeah you can write one
of those in the eye ocular totally
thoughts hard to get that foam adding a
perfect I don't know man worse I I
watched the story that this was a
television story that that we were
reading uh that we were looking at it
interview that cuz you understood that
the reporter as the make an effort is
one of the problems with the media is
that they can't do the story and go this
is obviously about liability and this is
stupid right so they go they talk to
somebody in the ER there and they got
and I asked him you know can't even see
in at school and of course we've been
seeing is the same injuries he's always
see ya because well that injuries bumps
it's great yeah yeah brain finger I just
might just break it down everything's
fine yeah alright so ruling the legal
part out of this for a second because
it's obviously about the legal part why
is it that they always want to cut the
things that are important like if I was
to look back on childhood which was
pretty pretty decent i went to pretty
decent school system like if they could
have done anything different i would say
more recess if I had a kid right now I
want them to take more music classes and
more art classes and not be zoning out
like I did during all the other class
why do we always go to the seemingly
good things just because we're a bunch
of liberal hippies here you liberal I
don't even know maybe they just want
everyone to be like pale and not see
sunshine or something that's a good
aspect i rather vitamin D for these kids
I remember years ago when I was doing
the show with jay was doing the the
young turks with Jack and there was a
story i'm pretty sure was in dallas and
at graduation they wouldn't allow
teachers faculty members whether it was
the principal or just a teacher during
graduation to hug a student like you
know you see your teacher who's like
been there for years near like you know
Larry way to go good luck to you right
they don't want it because of the fear
of the feelings of the unhooked oh my
god I swear to god that's a quote profit
so ladies in case this guy was playing
favorites basic right not yet but it's
falling favorites but like if he's not
gonna hug everyone you can again
hate that rule right it's crazy well
that's the cupcake rule the third grade
cupcake will if it's your birthday have
to bring in cupcakes for everybody yeah
and and so you can for and then there
were schools that would allow birthdays
to happen any birthday celebration at
all because of the kids who had
birthdays in June July August who didn't
get to celebrate the birthdays at school
let me taste the unhedged kids in Dallas
ER okay that's a great point maybe this
is like a case of I don't know they're
just defending the nerds and orchids
that aren't good at sports and they're
like well these kids aren't good at
sports so now no one can play sports
hahaha yeah but isn't that dangerous
though like even if you were to
prescribe that to the to the bullying
thing which obviously there is a
bullying problem in middle schools and
high schools or whatever but that you
get bullied in real life too hastily
you're gonna be bullied far more in real
life than as a kid so if you take all of
that out and you take out the
competitiveness and learning how to be a
team player in kickball or whatever you
take all that out of childhood then you
dump some kid out into the real world
and yeah you're gonna get far more
bullied than you were before right
absolutely I'm getting a lot of head
knives out of you so I think you're I
think you're on the crazy I think you
nailed that for sure bullying we
eliminate bullying you don't eliminate
everything else and and again you gotta
be grades of bullying but you know soon
as you tell school administrators who
are there some great people in school
but yeah running schools but we start to
school administration as soon as you
apply that zero tolerance policy then
you're expelling kids for bringing a
plastic knife to peel their orange you
know and it's a zero tolerance is almost
never works unless it's like zero
tolerance for rape right you know I mean
I think we can prank we take a
Republicans have says it'll shut it down
mostly right minimal tolerance yeah yeah
so I i I'm I'm with you it's a crazy
story and it makes us it makes the whole
country look bad I don't like a final
thought I went to a an arts boarding
school for my junior and senior year of
high school and our PE was hacky sack
because we played soccer once and they
had to cancel that because you can't
hurt the musicians because they need
their hands or play their musical
instruments so that's I mean with the
lack of sports physical activity look
what happened to me those go to say I'm
super pale I stay indoors a lot I'm kind
of antisocial today
you're early computer all the time but
what if ya a ki sachi I'm not learning
any apparently masturbate too much it's
a lot of [ __ ] went wrong with you but
hacky said you could hurt yourself with
hat he said twisted ankle which then if
you're what's give me an instrument that
you might need your foot for piano piano
when they're you give me a thousand
instruments to the user foot for a piano
would not have been hey guys the Ruby
report is brought to you by Cooper calm
you can get up to seventy-five percent
off pet toys choose all kinds of treats
and more the link is right down below
click it and use code RR for twenty
percent off your first purchase